عبد الله مثال عمره 20 سنه اتوقع بعد
عشرين سنه بنشوف تطورات كبيره في كافه
المجالات خاصه في التكنولوجيا والذكاء
الاصطناعي واستكشاف الفضاء راح يكون في
قوه اندماج بين البشريه والروبوتات وايضا
راح ننتقل في حقبه جديده من الوفره في
الطاقه والثروه الطبيعيه وباذن الله نشوف
الدول العربيه في تطور اكبر حلل واحد يكون
على طول متفائل
وعشرين سنه نظري الاعلام وصناعه الاعلام
راح تتغير كلين كلاس سنوات المقبله خصوصا
بعد ظهور برنامج
الاعلاميه ايضا برنامج نيكس لعاده مشاهد
وصور واقعيه فنحن نتكلم عن برامج تستعمل
مواد كثيره تشكل فريق كامل بدال
الاعلاميين والمهنيين فهذا التطور كبير
جدا بنظري راح يساعدني كثير اعلاميه اوصل
الغامدي عمري 20 سنه راني يكون العالم بعد
20 سنه اكثر تطورا وحداثه وازدهار في جميع
النواحي لا سيما تلك الاعلاميه كما اتوقع
ان يسود الاعلام الرقمي المؤسسات وين يكون
هو شكل واجهه الاعلام بالمستقبل
عمري 20 سنه
الاعلام عن متجدد دائما ومتطور وينظر
اليوم الى الاعلام بمنظور التسم بقدر عالي
من الاهتمام والتركيز والاعلام بعد 20 سنه
سيكون مختلف تماما عن الالام الحالي لوجود
الذكاء الاصطناعي ووسائل التقنيه الحديثه
والروبوتات بحيث ان الاجيال القادمه
استختلف رغباتهم وهوياتهم اختلافا كليا عن
الاجيال الحاليه
طالب اعلام عمره 20 سنه توقع العالم بعد
عشرين عام
العالم راح يشهد نقله جذريه خصوصا مع دخول
الويب 3 والذكاء الاصطناعي وهذا راح يسهل
شيء كثير
من الاعمال خصوصا في الجوانب الحياتيه لكن
الشيء اللي انا متاكد منه ومتيقن منه ان
العربيه راح تكون رفيق دايم لنا بالابداع
والاسبقيه
[موسيقى]
انا اسمي سجاد عمري بالعشرينات اتوقع منا
العشرين سنه بعد ماكو شي اسمه وظيفه
حكوميه الوظائف في قطاع الخاص بس واتوقع
بعض الوظائف راح تختفي من ضمنها الطيار
ومهندس الكهرباء واتجاه نحو التكنولوجيا
بالسيارات والتحول من البنزين الى
الكهرباء انا اسمي حسين شاب عشريني اتوقع
بعد عشرين سنه يكون تعليمي بين رقمي
والواقعي الافتراضي
ومستقبل افضل ان شاء الله
ونحو التطور وتكنولوجيا اللي ينفتح عليها
العالم لكل مستوياته وكل الاصعده والنواحي
[موسيقى]
انا اسمي محمد عمري 20 سنه اتوقع ان شاء
الله بالزمن المستقبلي انه راح يصير تغير
واسع
بالتكنولوجيا وراح نقوم ما
نحتاجون الرقمي اللي احنا نستخدمه هسه
ربما راح يتطور اكثر حسب توقعي
وهذا الشي راح يساعدنا بمجالات شتى
بموضوع الدراسه احتمال احتمال موضوع
المعاملات اللي هسه بنواجه بها صعوبات
بالدوائر انا اسمي سجاد عمري بالعشرينات
ان شاء الله اذا اشوف انه اكو تطور بهاي
الفتره المستقبليه خلال عشرين سنه تطور
التكنولوجيا وكل شيء يعني ان شاء الله
بالعصر الحديث راح يصير بيه تطور بالعمار
بالتكنولوجيا من خلال كل البلدان بالعالم
وخصوصا العراق
[موسيقى]